CBS news political correspondent ed
Keith ed O'Keefe is here ed good morning
see you guys again
so do binds dividers I know you've been
talking to them with this video do they
feel like they're close to being able to
move on from this issue well I think
earlier this week there was a thought
that if there was nothing more serious
alleged by anyone than they would be
alright in so now they've released this
video we noticed he acknowledges it he
says he's gonna do better he doesn't
explicitly apologize to these women that
was part of the debate there's a really
anything to apologize for not what
you're just going to explain yourself
wrong which is what he did and most of
the women it seems that are saying they
would still vote for him that they don't
think it disqualifies him from being a
presidential candidate yeah as one of
them said and this doesn't explicitly
disqualify him but we should have a
robust debate about his 40 years of
public service and some of the things
that he did in the past as a senator
let's talk about the larger 2020 race I
understand the dozen of the Democrats
that are running for president are all
gonna be speaking in an event well
they're here in New York yes
the annual al Sharpton National Action
Network conference one of the many what
we like to call cattle calls that will
be held across the country this year and
next year they're traveling in packs
this week it's midtown Manhattan because
they hope that if they can make it here
they can make it anywhere what are you
looking for in the speeches well one of
the things that this group the National
Action Network has told them they want
to hear about is support for potential
reparations for slavery as one of the
leaders told us yesterday at the event
we want to know that these Democratic
candidates are at least open to the idea
of possible reparations being paid this
is an issue that has been talked about
by a lot of these candidates hasn't been
talked about broadly but there are
different groups and people trying to
push it into the conversation it'll be
interesting is what is the threshold do
they all just have to say yes it'd be
interesting to have a community to study
it or they have to be specific about
what reparations and they want to see at
least people say I'm okay with the idea
let's talk about it more let me ask you
this are we in the stage ad with these
cattle calls as so many of them are
candidates in the stage of hi nice to
meet you here's who I am or are they in
the stage of here's how I'm different
than this person or that person
it's more still introducing yourself to
these audiences trying to explain your
background and in some cases putting on
some pretty meaty proposals on things
that they would do whether it's
immigration whether
reforming the tax structure or revamping
health care in the country but you know
you ask most Americans to name more than
three presidential candidates right now
and they can't do it they shouldn't have
to write because this is still fun you
know much more than a year away let's
talk about fundraising numbers John were
you gonna say something weird in this
let's talk about the fundraising numbers
you know Bernie said the other day 18
million
qumola said 12 million better or work is
now up to nine and he he's touting that
these are more individual donations
smaller donations I think mayor Pete
blue de jedge is 6.9 what oh there's a 7
mil plus now yeah 7 million plus okay
the other Davidson so these are the only
people yeah these are the only four of
the candidates to self announce they've
raised so far so what does this tell you
what does this mean well you know it's
no surprise that Bernie Sanders would
have as much as he does he's he's
probably the biggest name in the race
and had several million dollars left
over from his last campaign this is one
of the only data points we have at this
point one of the only pieces of evidence
of potential support and so they're
gonna sort of be touting the fact that
you know our largest contribution was
only $40 and we got it from 900,000
there were 900 thousand different
contributions why does that matter
it matters because it demonstrates that
they have support across the country the
kind of grassroots support that will
sustain them both financially and on the
ground in these early primaries day I
read one donor to the judge say I've
given him $10 and every week I just give
another tab yeah every day right that's
the kind of enthusiasm right you gotta
build when someone keeps keeps watching
the channels and says I'm sending
another check I know we gotta go but
that's really those top four a lot of
diversity and those top four fund
raising candidates just reminds you how
to verse the field absolutely alright ed
O'Keefe you coming back layers is it for
today I think this is a double matinee
always good I like a met Nate